well
this is definitely a change of pace
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
i will be reviewing dutch fitness
youtuber sophie from gainsby brains also
check out my disclaimer on screen and in
the description including a quick
trigger warning as always skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey also if you're new here do not
forget to subscribe and ring that bell
so that you never miss out on an episode
alright so
sophie from games by brains is a
certified personal trainer with a
master's degree from the netherlands who
shares customized programs and
self-branded fitness equipment as well
as lots of free content on her youtube
channel so i watched her recent level up
series and i'm specifically going to
focus in on episode two because she's
sharing both her eating philosophy and
how she improved her relationship with
food as well as a day of eating so let's
take a look at her first meal my first
meal is usually oats i add nuts or seeds
and nut butter to add some healthy fats
to the meal so i quickly whipped out
some egg scramble with cabbage and for
that i'm cutting some garlic red onion
and cabbage i heat some oil in the pan
and then i add the garlic and onion and
then i add two eggs and one egg white
this also increases the fats because of
the oil in the pan and the yolks okay so
the combination of the oatmeal bowl with
the egg cabbage situation makes a
perfectly balanced and super satiating
meal so we've got fiber rich carbs in
the oats berries and the cabbage we got
protein in the eggs plus some fats in
the nuts egg yolks and oil that she
mentioned and she mentions that on days
that she's really busy she gets her
protein fixed from like a protein shake
so i really like that she has both a
fast food option and a slow food option
for getting her protein in the morning
so she can easily switch it up while
keeping meals balanced depending on what
time and ingredients she has on hand
also that crispy cabbage egg situation
i am stealing that and whenever i order
takeaway as i did for lunch here i try
to pick something that i love eating and
that fits with my approach so i got some
avocado on toast with eggs and a green
juice simple and it's one of my
favorites this looks like a lovely
nutrient dense and likely very delicious
restaurant option
so we've got protein in the eggs fiber
in the bread and some avocado we've got
fat in the egg yolks and the avocado
plus lots of micronutrients in the juice
as well and while yes this is pretty
much the epitome of a wellness
influencer's lunch what i love here is
that it isn't coming served with a side
of diet culture it's just like she's
saying you know i choose foods that i
enjoy that fit my values it's not i
drink green juice to detox and speed up
my metabolism folks
intention is key choosing green juice
because it makes you feel energized and
refreshed and because you like the
flavor is a really healthy choice in my
books but choosing green juice to punish
yourself for eating pizza the day before
not so much do you see the distinction
and then i'm also roasting some pine
nuts for the healthy fats and then i
just add everything together add a
yogurt dressing and voila super
delicious and colorful if you ask me
okay this looks amazing
and also super well balanced so we've
got fat in the dressing and nuts we got
protein in the chicken carbs in the
fries and lots of fiber and antioxidants
in the salad i also really appreciate
that sophie isn't scared of using oil
but it's also all about smart use of oil
where it helps to add flavor and
nutrition so knowing that air frying
those french fries will still yield the
flavor and texture that she enjoys she
can kind of hold off on the oil there
and enjoy a full fat dressing on her
salad greens this is to me what balance
is all about now in this video she
doesn't show any snacks but this video
also wasn't explicitly labeled as like a
what in a day so it's very possible that
they just weren't shown but when i
watched her what in a week video she did
show that she often has some kind of
like yogurt cup or chocolate rice cakes
for a snack both delicious options when
you're craving just like a little some
something to get you that next meal but
if she wanted to hunger crush and combo
that
she could throw some nut butter onto the
rice cakes or throw some high fiber
cereal or fruit on the yogurt which i
actually saw her do at one point in that
video as well all right so let's take a
look at the stats here now this was a
bit hard to judge as i wasn't sure if
there would be a snack in there but i
would say appear to be around the 2000
calorie mark with around 55 percent of
calories from carbs 20 from fat 25 from
protein and around 30 grams of fiber so
this to me is a really super balanced
diet and depending on her activity level
a decent amount of calories as well
which of course is nice to see okay so
in order to share my thoughts on
sophie's diet and approach to food i
really want to zone in and comment on
some of her sentiments about how she
changed her relationship with food so
let's take a look and this started with
me figuring out what my macro should be
what my intake should be and i just did
it by calculating and using formulas i
started tracking macros and just trying
to find my way in what i was providing
my body versus what my body needed to
feel best
and
what i learned is that you have to stick
with something that works for you so
okay first of all
these online macro calculators are
designed to loosely predict caloric
needs with
modest accuracy it's certainly not meant
to prescribe them so age height weight
activity body composition all will play
a role in addition to things that you
can't really account for in a calculator
like health status genetics medications
climate sleep etc there's also the
nuance inactivity output that really
just can't be captured by simply asking
if you do light moderate or heavy
activity now i actually tried her
calculator myself and because there's
strangely no option to just like
maintain my body the way it is in all of
its mom-bod glory i selected the recomp
feature aka to reduce body fat and
increase muscle so i was told that i
need 2023 calories which is definitely
less than what i eat but of course again
i'm not trying to change my mom body so
i asked my colleague chelsea cross who
specializes in sports nutrition and she
suggested that most people actually
aren't able to easily recomp just from
manipulating their diet alone for
someone who isn't completely new to
weightlifting or having a protocol for
dieting and exercise building muscle is
more optimized in a slight surplus
in which some gain and fat is to be
expected this doesn't have to be a large
surplus however true recomposition
often takes time of being in the slight
surplus and dieting while also being
intentional and consistent with their
training and recovery protocols so i
don't think it's realistic to expect
that there's any kind of magic macro
split that allows you to gain muscle
while losing fat now recomp calculations
aside i think is a very very rough
starting place these numbers could be
potentially somewhat helpful for some
people but i agree with sophie that at
the end of the day you really have to
find a way of eating that feels best to
you some people are going to naturally
thrive on a higher carb lower fat diet
and others might just have more energy
and better blood sugar control eating
lower carb but a super basic calculator
online that considers only your body
weight and your rough activity level
is not going to accurately capture the
nuance and diversity of human metabolic
needs so via trial and error i figured
out what works best for me that being
said i have tracked macros previously
for a long time so i can estimate pretty
well what macros are of different dishes
so i know what i am eating even though
i'm not currently tracking and i don't
plan on tracking in the near future but
it is knowledge that i know that's in my
head and that i can apply whenever i
just look at something for example so
a lot of influencers talk about tracking
calories or macros for long enough that
this information becomes kind of second
nature or what they sometimes even call
intuitive and i don't think that this is
a bad approach i do believe that
knowledge is power and if knowing that a
potato has more carbs than an avocado
helps you plan satiating and balanced
hunger crushing combos i think that
that's great knowledge to have but i
also don't think that you need to reduce
foods down to a series of numbers or to
plug meals into an equation to be able
to effectively build healthy meals and
snacks so if you like math and this
doesn't interfere with your enjoyment of
life or take up so much mental energy
that it robs you of time for other acts
of self-care then fine like track those
macros you do you but i also think just
knowing something top level like the
fact that blueberries are a great source
of fiber-rich carbs and therefore they
can pair nicely with the fat and protein
in almonds
is totally enough for most people to
promote really good health i also think
that while macros may be important for
body composition
micronutrients are also very important
and rather than counting micros because
like that would be a full-time job
nope
we can really just focus on greater
variety and color so i say keep it
simple stupid and like let's just move
on with our lives and no i'm not calling
her stupid
that's just a very common phrase and
saying
the first step is to try to stick to
eating balanced meals this means that i
try to have three larger meals during
the day that consists of fats carbs and
protein i noticed that this helps me
feel full and satisfied for longer yeah
girl
get it you go girl
i mean she maybe doesn't know it but i
know that you know that we know
she's talking about the hunger crushing
combo
fiber protein and healthy fats and if
you want to learn more about that you
can check out my video right here for
loads of inspiration now do i think that
you need to weigh out your oats in order
to make healthy balanced choices no i
don't obviously but i also understand
that she has potentially some specific
body composition goals so
i mean to each their own the second step
is to try to stick to whole foods this
means that i try to keep the bulk of my
diet minimally processed examples are
whole grains fruits or vegetables so i
think this is a general good approach so
whether the goal is health related or
aesthetic we know that a diet rich in
whole foods is going to be a good bet
because these foods tend to be higher in
hunger crushing compounds like fiber
protein healthy fats plus antioxidants
and typically lower in saturated fats
salt and sugar but of course it's very
important not to demonize processed
foods and unlike most wellness
influencers i don't really think that
sophie does
so she seems pretty neutral in her
description of foods and seems to make
choices based on what just feels best to
her but also processed foods are not the
devil let's not forget that processing
makes a lot of healthy foods accessible
to us so yogurt canned tuna frozen
vegetables canned beans bread cheese
whole grain cereal are all examples of
nutrient-dense processed food so we
don't need to necessarily cut processed
foods completely out of our diet to
maintain a healthy balanced lifestyle
and whenever i order takeaway as i did
for lunch here i try to pick something
that i love eating and that fits with my
approach and this is ideally the way
that it should be you know we're eating
a way that both supports our physical
and emotional needs and therefore is
more likely to be maintained in the long
run third and final step is to keep it
colorful i know that these steps sound
so
simple
in a ted talk towards a science of
simplicity harvard professor george
whitesides actually breaks down simple
in three characteristics it's
predictable it's accessible and it
serves as building blocks predictable
accessible and serving as a set of
building blocks i love this philosophy
and to think of these guidelines as
building blocks rather than hard and
fast rules that are set in stone
so great i mean it's like something that
can be built upon based on your unique
needs and likes this is not unlike the
recommendations that i gave in my video
on gentle nutrition tips for weight loss
where i talked about focusing on what
you can add to your diet rather than
what you have to take away so shifting
the focus towards abundance rather than
denial is really the key to preventing
scarcity mentality and preventing the
all too common restrict binge cycle i
also agree that any way of eating needs
to feel accessible if you're having to
choose between affording the long list
of superfood powders on your goop
cleanse or milk for your kids cereal for
the week i would say that it's not a
very accessible long-term diet plan for
you and then there's predictable now a
lot of people assume that intuitive
eating is all about spontaneity and
living in the moment
and it can be but i think this approach
actually ostracizes or intimidates a lot
of us folks who really do thrive in a
stable predictable environment and
routine so predictability to me is not
about rigidity it's just about your body
having trust that you will feed it
regularly and feed it enough it's about
knowing and trusting that you don't
necessarily need to eat the entire batch
of cupcakes today because you know that
tomorrow is another opportunity for
deliciousness
now i acknowledge that food security
factors definitely come into play here
and i actually think that that's
something that the intuitive eating
model doesn't quite address
but assuming that that's not a major
concern
yes i do think that these three tenants
are great guidelines to eat by so
generally speaking i really enjoyed what
i see here in sophie's content she
doesn't seem to be cutting out full food
groups and eats by a set of values
rather than a set of die hard rules i
actually watched a bunch of her vlogs
and the meals in her wedding a week
seemed to echo this sentiment as well
and what i really love here is that
there's so much variety in her day and
week
we actually see a nice range of protein
sources fruits and veggies and starches
represented in her week so she clearly
is able to be flexible in her meal
planning while sticking to a general
formula of getting in her carbs fat and
protein in most meals
i also love that when she talks about
nutrition it's about using macros as
building blocks for building balanced
meals
rather than reducing food down to
sensationalized claims i really do
believe that when it comes to a healthy
diet the whole is greater than the sum
of its parts so we really need to think
big picture which i think that sophie
does pretty well with her diet nutrition
philosophy
obsessing over the mct content of
coconut oil or the cluster salts and
celery juice or the vitamin c and lemon
juice
reduces food down to a series of
unrelated numbers and totally misses the
forest from the trees the simpler we can
make healthy eating the more likely we
are to stick to it and i do think that
sophie's approach is one of the more
simpler evidence-based approaches that i
have seen in the wellness influencer
community and on that note that is all
for today's wedding day review if you
liked it be sure to give it the thumbs
up
leave me a comment below on who you want
to see me review next subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye